though the big moment of this year's mtv
video music awards wasn't working Miley
Cyrus still managed to steal the show by
sending a homeless youth to accept her
award and make a statement the music
industry will make over seven billion
dollars this year and outside these
doors are 54,000 human beings who have
no place to call home whether or not it
was just a stunt to improve Miley's
image the stats don't lie the number of
homeless people in Los Angeles County is
close to 54,000 that's the second
largest homeless population in a US city
behind new york city which has 64,000 in
the United States as a whole there were
six hundred and ten thousand homeless
people on any given night in 2013 nearly
one-fourth of them were children under
the age of 18 nearly two-thirds were in
emergency shelters or transitional
housing programs while the remaining
one-third are unsheltered the states
with the largest homeless populations
California New York and Florida
subscribe on YouTube follow us on
Twitter and like us on Facebook